ça va pas oh j'ai mal au crâne [ __ ]
depuis qu elle a sorti le clip avec
maxence nous a été pas de faire des
compliments et j'ai pris la grosse tête
ok ok ok on arrête les bêtises il est
vrai vos avis sont positifs et il est
vrai j'aime pas avoir la grosse tête
alors j'ai besoin qu'on me casse ont 2
auquel je fais un petit tweet en vous
demandant de me clash et intelligemment
pour remédier à ce problème de grosses
têtes pour équilibrer la balance entre
les compliments et les insultes bien
évidemment new qui nous dit ton visage
on dirait un chameau merci dieu on ne
fera plus jamais de vidéos ensemble tu
te prends pour un dalton avec tes bottes
et un stetson mais laisse moi te
rappeler que ton nom est personne
on s'est bien trouvé sa transaction avec
tes potes ton stenson et laisse moi te
rappeler que son père sa plage ils
sapent la ji ivey l'on fait tout âge en
son nom toute la chanson tous ensemble
c'est mignon cet os
j'ai la grosse tête auquel fomc lâché
l'info pas faut pas provoquer des
réactions comme ça de minions ta masse
musculaire fait le poids de mon petit
cousin prématuré ce attaques sur le
physique tout de suite mais voilà
franchement ça vole pas haut tes vidéos
c'est de la merde arrête youtube ce te
plait mr merki merci ça me faire
descendre un jeu sans journée sans
continuer lucas gevers des vidéos depuis
quatre ans et a pu la retenir toujours
pas arrivé et la barbe je la soupçonne
d'être une fausse barbe mdr ah oui
continuer font pas trop la grosse tête
ça paraîtra difforme à côté de ton corps
de lâches et ce qu'on fait tout de suite
toutes les vannes qui concerne mon corps
de lâche sa plus simple pour les faits
tout d'affilée comme ça fait le festival
des vannes sur le corps de l'âge de
squeeze c'est parti c'est maintenant au
moins tu as tu es te fera peut-être
atteindre le mètre soixante dix petits
cons malgré ta barbe tu n'es pas encore
viril jeunes corde là tu vas pas
redescendre bien au but à taille et à
peut-être la grosse tête mais tes bras
sont toujours aussi petit smiley tire la
langue
ah parce qu'elle n'était pas déjà
grosses stats est désolé squeeze mais si
tu prend la grosse tête avec ton corps
antijeu tu pense pas que ça va faire
coton tige blanc c'est nul c nul squeeze
avec la grosse tête ça ressemble à une
figurine pop est mort hier soir en
lisant vos commentaires sur la vidéo sur
le clip j'étais vraiment comme ça s'est
livrée elle proportion [ __ ] ils sont
drôles ses abonnés se fout-on flou et
comme le muscle de ton bras droit plein
c'est blessant talent et bras de bob
l'eponge ouais et alors n'oublie pas que
j'ai doublé - dans ce film et je sais
très bien qu'il ya une image où il
possède d'énormes bras vu ce qui les a
c'est tellement vrai que quand tu montes
sur la balance il écrit veuillez monter
sur la balance
je connaissais pas cette blague et
original tu es tellement moche quand on
fait du stop personnes arrêtent et vous
êtes chaud là et tranquille aussi un peu
la barbade a des trous simple mais
pourtant si efficace j'ai rien à ajouter
de plus que shia qu'est-ce qu'il ya un
an visiblement ça commence à pousser dur
à la salle bibi et début de pecs fière
de toi assez bon le festival est terminé
merci à tous d'être venus
rappelle-toi les vidéos de 2010 non
alban album bon je trouve que c'est un
peu petit d'en arriver là de jaar parce
que ma vidéo sur ds 2 j'ai pas pu la
sortir dans les temps la bonne est obéré
nice toulouse et qui est très mignon
pourquoi te lâcher quand une musique est
aussi agréable à écouter ce qui m'arrive
quand je vois ça c'est chaud thé
tatouage c'est comme ta vie on peut les
effacer facilement je crois qu'il va
compris le principe du tatouage à
waldemar haut pour une fois que tu
t'éloignes du style depuis dubaï c'est
pour s'immiscer dans celui de maxence
leur [ __ ] il est en tête du classement
fais gaffe tête à tête se gonfle pas à
l'hélium sinon il n'y a pas que ta
modestie qui va s'envoler
[ __ ] c'est au ris parce que c'est très
recherché mais c'est quand même un nul
pire force heures au monde
ah [ __ ] ça me fait mal à tous et des
podcasts était tellement nul que tu t'es
reconverti dans le gaming pop up auquel
vodka gbot deuil a pas de podcasts
jamais fait podcasts et wisi on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour nous tout
premier podcast c'est pas moi c'est pas
moi ça je sais ce que je ressemble déjà
non c'est pas moi jalousie au photoshop
j'ai rien à rajouter sinon si j'avais su
un jour que ce concept repose sur des
barres parallèles les gens meurent
ajouterait une carte et me mettrai dans
du ciel va sans rien changer à ma vie ma
[ __ ] est plus grosse que ton soi-disant
talent en chant [ __ ] doigt est énorme
ps je suis une fille
oh non message à tous les coups qui se
croient au dessus des autres regardez
votre vie en vendant les de luke adam de
macaques
non mais hayat rami camille t'énerve pas
c'est le but de cette vidéo j'ai demandé
il ya trop d'amour c'était une beauté je
trouve ça beau je trouve ça beau
franchement j'aime bien c'est trop nul
ah [ __ ] l'unc mais franchement terrain
matt hardy assad dans tout le monde
c'est blessant tu vois quand je te dis
des trucs comme ça quand on est tous les
deux tués répète-t-on public je te plaît
franchement ces rouleaux bon au vu que
j'ai réussi à casser l'ambiance est
moins d'acteurs de merde c'était beau
rester bosses tu es beau tu es beau fils
lots achetés
j'ai toujours préféré monsieur dream moi
aussi mais aussi avec maxence de des
fonds ce bras de fer
ouais pas d'argumenter qui met ko mais
karzaï a pris la grosse tête là à me
dire tu es qui [ __ ] étaient 23 en
conneries la fan de jeu vidéo disney
streamer de 12 heures à 12 heures une
cote promis qu'à l'eau pour le premier
mois quoi quoi tu es un vendu tu fais
des vrais placement tu es tellement pas
respecté que kanté passe en arrière dans
la vidéo de toute ma carrière à fait le
cas et j'ai cru que c'était un stagiaire
merde alors non par contre j'aurais
kiffé faire un stage comme ça un mec je
peux dire que mon stage l'effet
intermarché mongai faisait moins cinq
degrés on veut offrir des packs en
plastique avec nos doigts parce qu'ils
voulaient pas nous lâcher de cutter par
peur qu'on se blesse du coup se blesser
encore plus que si on avait vraiment à
coeur vous avez vu c'est le vécu qui
parle t 15 salle daltoniens au hockey il
a joué le jeu avec des handicapés les
gens n'aiment pas les jockeys chiens
errants la violence c'est par chercher
mais ça passe crème l'insultent gratuite
ce mec et sado maso où il fait une vidéo
en tout cas ça derrière musique était
grave cool merci mec c'est sympa aussi
cool que jul
tous ces pousses bug du croyais avoir il
était rouge mais comme tu es [ __ ]
daltoniens tu croyais faire des bonnes
vidéos qu'on franchement il y avait un
beau coup mais tes pattes et dans un
truc qui n'est plus du français
du coup j'arrive plus à comprendre des
phrases les gens en france sont
tellement insultes et que tu as décidé
d'aller en corée
ouais alors j'ai intégré un groupe de
kate porte mon pote et on dirait cyprien
mais avec moins de cheveux irene khan
visuellement - bio c'est sûr ils plus
vieux normalement une calvitie avant moi
toujours dans le grade ma voix qu'au
fond ça m'a blessé qu'au fond vous avez
trouvé la petite faille
la petite faille qui blesse vraiment
squeeze andré siaka mais c'est que je
montre j'ai même pas vu le clip hold up
était bien celle là j'ai une bonne
nouvelle les amis je n'ai plus la grosse
tête c'est bon vous m'avez calmez vous
m'avez calmer ma grosse trace ya eu de
tout là sur le physique sur le physique
sur le physique c'était fou n'hésitez
pas à me les dossiers elle vous a plu je
n'ai pas la grosse tête je suis de
nouveau comme avant ça me fait plaisir
je pourrais dire oh mec qui me dit elle
change paraissent contest inquiète
j'avais changé mais j'ai fait ce qu'il
faut et je suis moi même
what a girl par contre ok je veux plein
de bisous en réalité je vous remercie
pour cet accueil exceptionnel pour la
vidéo placement de produit c'est juste
d'un long été trop content avec maxence
toute l'équipe était trop content qu'ils
ont vu aussi tout ce que vous avez dit
merci pour tout et puis je vous dire
très vite dans une prochaine vidéo bien
sûr avec une voix bien sûr de
l'animateur de fête foraine attention
c'est partir de la traction 3,2 hors
let's go
[Musique]